q good morning um my name is a DRDs and
this is Robin tawa we are data crash lab
we help teens and organizations with the
technology solutions and their data
analytics we love to support the local
data science community and PI data
Carolinas is part of the work that we do
with the community so we have been part
of the board of organizers on behalf of
the board of organizers and ourselves we
welcome you to PI data Carolinas so this
morning we are going to be talking about
scalable data science with spark and are
if you try to install spark are no worry
about it we will work in a hostile
environment earlier we show the
information about data breaks we will
show that again at the appropriate
moment the intended audience for this
tutorial are people that are familiar
with our people that are familiar with
machine learning concepts but they may
be new to spark are if you are not
familiar with our or spa or machine
learning or know a lot about spark talk
to your neighbor and help each other out
and hopefully and we hope that that week
and you can follow along so the
objectives for our tutorial today we're
going to be rob is going to give us a a
brief overview of the basic concepts of
spark then we're going to go into the
data rate environment to learn how to
explore data in spark are perform
interactive analysis and hopefully we'll
have enough time to run machine learning
algorithms in spark are so Rob Thank You
Sadie and good morning everyone I hope
everyone is as excited as we are to
share our knowledge of the technology
and that we also hope that this is going
to be an a formatted session for you and
that you take the most benefit from the
experience as a de ulua to a second ago
my contribution my main two
objectives that I would like to
accomplish with my part of the
presentation is to number one to provide
a very brief overview high-level
conceptual overview of a spark and most
important paved the way for your
interaction with the notebook you will
be using with the tutorial that said
only if it works so spark is a
general-purpose cluster computing system
that provides support for fault
tolerance which means that if a node in
the cluster goes down or a node is
acting too slow another node from the
cluster will pick a pick up the slack
and effectively restore the performance
in the functionality to the system as a
whole the complexity associated with
maintaining these fault tolerance is
hidden from the programmers behind the
api's in the runtime spark also
partitions big data across multiple
nodes in a cluster and stores the data
and this is very important to notice on
the memory in these nodes and you will
see later why this storing data memory
is actually very important and very
critical so spark offers a targeted
support for certain use cases such as
structured data in relational queries
via spark SQL it provides support for
processing of real-time strings we
aspired streaming it also has a built-in
library for machine learning and it
supports graph processing the graph the
graphics API
so at this point in time some of you
might be wondering why spark well the
short answer is that spark is actually
very fast and there's reasons why spark
achieves such speed and one of them has
to do with the fact that it supports
massively parallel computation which
implies coordinated execution of code by
multiple processors that work in
different parts of the program with each
processor using its other ways and
memory as I said earlier one of the main
salient features of spark is a it keeps
data in memory some of you may be
familiar with Hadoop Hadoop also has a
similar concept except that the data is
kept in memory and sometimes building to
the hard drive and there's a cycle
usually that goes from hard drive to
memory and that IO bottleneck presents
performance issues for Hadoop this is
strongly minimized by spark keeping
things in memory another feature that
makes Park fast is a spark is also
partitioning aware which means that it
knows where to keep the data and what
notes to keep the data close to in other
words trying to avoid shuffling data
over the network and therefore reduces
the impact of network latencies if you
are interested in writing an application
for spark or using spark their support
for writing an application using scala
java python and are and if you know SQL
you will some of the constructs that are
provided by spark are going to be very
familiar to you one important concept
that i wanted to highlight is the fact
that a spark application consists of
essentially two programs a driver and
executor or executors and the driver you
can think of it as as a main or the main
loop that exit is a cold
any dros on one machine and the executor
usually runs on machines in the cluster
and that's how it achieves the parallel
execution of code one concept that I
wanted to bring to your attention is the
r dds you might have heard of resilient
distributed data sets and it is a the
main abstraction that spark utilizes
four elements that are partition across
nodes in a cluster for parallel
processing with a spark 2 point 0 which
is the support we will be using today
with a zaly tutorial they change the
nomenclature to be spark data frame as
opposed to data frame it's still the
same concept and it is essentially
distributed collection of data into name
columns conceptually similar to a table
in relational database some interesting
and important properties spark data
frames how r that a number one spark
data frame is immutable in other words
that once it is created is now it cannot
be changed so as you will see throughout
the code there will be multiple
interaction or operations against data
frames that implies that you start with
a data frame the operation or the
transformation changes our data frame
into a new data frame and that
essentially translates into data frames
being created on the fly in response to
an action we will get to a little bit
later on other properties that data and
for data frames are distributed across
all the executor is in a cluster they
can be created from many different
sources Hadoop file system text files
Jason porque hoy Vetsera data frames can
be cashed in memory for later use so if
your application throughout your
application you may want to deliberately
request that a spark data frame be
cached because by default once the data
frame is used it basically gets
destroyed once it's no longer
needed data frame most of a schema which
implies that they have to have a name
associated with each column and a type
for each one of the elements in that
column as I alluded to earlier
operations in spark can be classified
into either transformations or actions
transformations are lazily evaluated
what that means is that they're not
executed immediately when the call is
made but rather an interaction happens
with other back-end components that
effectively create an execution plan
only when an action is triggered and
that's the other type of operation only
when an action is explicitly requested
the transformation code is actually
executed and obviously we create a new
spark data frame from an existing one
the actions as I mentioned earlier is
the main mechanism for spark to get
results and it is what triggers the
execution of the transformations so this
point in time we're getting to the point
where I will be very close to handing it
over to zaidi for the main part of the
presentation the most important one I'd
like to bring to your attention that we
are using a hosted environment called
data bricks I know that some of you
approached those at the very beginning
and told us that he had run into
problems with setting spark up this may
be beneficial for those of you for
everyone but really for those of you who
had problems with that this will be a
lot easier should be a lot more
straightforward and less hassles so
these are the instructions by show of
hands is anyone here in need of help
with setting up the data brakes account
or has any issues after having tried to
do so
by the way we have been here to help
danny is very familiar with data breaks
and he will definitely be able to assist
if you run into any issues another thing
that I wanted to highlight is that data
breaks specifically states that they
only support google chrome so those of
you who are in apple or are in windows
that are using Internet Explorer you may
run into issues it's they claim it is
unsupported you may get it to work
somehow however if you are running into
any limitations please let us know you
may want to switch to google chrome or
partner up with someone that is that is
running Google Chrome yes
they will be along with in the notebook
by the way so if you run into any issues
the notebook will be published and you
will have access to it along with our
contact information so if you're run
into any issues feel free to try things
on your own and contact us let us know
if you if we can help in any way so
without any further ado you get over so
I'm going to transfer it over to zaidi
and thank you very much for coming and I
hope you have a great rest of the day
okay so um hopefully everybody is inside
of data bricks already and they have the
bitly open in another window because now
you need to grab that URL it's a very
long URL and working your data breaks
account let me switch back to data
breaks okay
so you you may be in this view where
this is the home view oh you cannot see
my window just a sec okay so now we're
in data breaks i press the home view you
do you may see the workspace users and
your username and that's where you will
see the the pop-up go to import which
says import item the URL you cannot
enter the Billy URL there because you
will not resolve you need to grab the
long URL that we that you had from the
bit ly before in here
try that
you
okay and then press import to get to the
what do you need I don't want to do that
okay anyone needs help getting to
importing their notebook now okay
perfect so to run this tutorial we need
to create a cluster and we're going to
do it over here at the top you may see
detached if you are detached then click
on on that and that logo and they will
ask you to going to be brave and detach
your work terminate it that was brave so
you may be asked to create a new cluster
let's see
create a cluster you give it a name now
make sure that the apache spark version
is dew point now Scarlett 211 rally at
the at the end of your system some of
the of the code that we have in there
are specific to spark to point out then
you will click create your cluster and
wait
okay at this point anyone needs help
attaching to their cluster
mine seems to be deploying
to ha right
anyone else needs help dashing through
clusters okay we have we need help over
here
so we seem to be having Wi-Fi issues so
so what do we wait for everybody to
attach one of the main things that I
want to put a picture in your head about
spark r is the idea that we have a
driver program and worker nodes are and
spark are live in the driver area in the
driver program everything else is is
part of spark so to be able to access
the data that is in the exact turn
executor nodes we have to communicate
and undo the api's so we're going to be
looking at how we're going to bring data
back and forth from they are to spark
and what to do and not to do about that
the kind of data still in some more help
so this notebook is already in our
notebook when you do it for the first
time yes you have to create the language
you have to select what language you're
going to be using yes so that's that's
when you are trying to do a new a new
notebook and I will try to do this that
this is where you create a new notebook
and you put a name and do you select the
language that you want yeah but this
notebook that we had already that we had
already created is already in our and we
can see it at the top this is the name
that I select a sparker tutorial and in
the parenthesis sr22 indicate that
that's what what is running
ok
okay so as we indicated before our
objectives are to understand the basic
concepts of spark we're going to be
doing data exploration performing
interactive analysis and running machine
learning algorithms a summation we need
to make sure that you're attached to a
cluster run in spark to point o and
skyla Skala 211 to navigate between the
cells in in data bricks you can use ctrl
+ Enter and that runs the code in the in
the cells now if you use a spark are in
another environment this is hosted
environment and they are already going
up putting together the context and
doing all of the configuration for us we
don't need to do that but if you're
running spark are in your own
environment or hosted in another
platform you may have to do library
spark are and then start the session in
spark dew point 0 is called spark our
session but in previous versions of
spark our it was a spark are in it so
make sure that depending on where you
are trying to run this you know what
command to use to get started anyone
everybody attached no one else having
issues so we still have one one more
issue 2 3
and to make sure that you're attached
you can run the first command SQ a
context and it will give you an ID
so I have annotated the cells with some
of my comments and but also I've tried
to bring in some of the manual page
descriptions for some of the so for the
spark our commands so if you run this at
home you will be able to have that as a
reference okay we are going to proceed
with the tutorial in if you would like
to work with your neighbor or follow
along as as we as we move so the first
the second comment that we're going to
run is the spark outcome that tells us
what the configuration for our session
is he gives us a lot of information but
the the one that I wanted to look at is
richer concerning the spark drivermax
results eyes so if you scroll down on
the window to find that spark driver max
rizal sighs it's four gig what they have
done is when they configured the driver
node what they are telling the executors
is do not send me more than four gig or
my driver would run out of memory and
that wouldn't be a good thing so that is
the configuration in there but it's
something to keep in mind when you are
writing your code
you it refers to the data that the
executor sent back to the driver node
okay so let's not get started with the
exploration of the data we're going to
be looking at the differences between
executing a command in our and in spark
okay i'm trying i'm going to give you an
overview about if you are still having
issues let us know and we can try to
help you with that so we're going to
learn in this in this particular part
how to bring data into spark are and how
to perform some structured data
processing what we're going to be using
is the exploring the Old Faithful geyser
data how many of you have been to
yellowstone that must be a sight to see
I've never been but it is called all
faithful because it is said to to erupt
exactly at hourly intervals so one of
the our datasets is a historic data or
about the wait time between eruptions
and how long the eruptions lasted so
we're going to be looking at that it is
not big data and as we will see but we
will see how to get that from the our
environment into the spark environment
and how to work with it out in this Park
environment as an exercise for the
reader you're welcome to bring in big
data to be able to do this with more
with more of your data set and I have
also included links to several a
reference material and one of the links
is the webcam for do Faithful geyser so
if you are lucky to hit it just at the
right time you will see the eruption so
what are the questions that we want to
be looking at
with the historical data going to be
looking at how long is the wait time
between eruptions how long is the
duration of an eruption and also we're
going to look at what's the most common
waiting time and for that waiting time
if you had to wait that long how long
was the duration I cluster doesn't seem
to be working but we'll try yeah maybe
their Wi-Fi it looks like I got it so if
you're from again if you're familiar
with our if you have the question mark
that's the brings up the documentation
and this is it this is a data set that
is usually in our you will see the
information it's a small data frame with
272 observations and the variables are
eruptions and waiting so have as Ron
mentioned the spark data frame used to
be called just data frames before the
point before sparked by know they have
been inspired by the work done in pandas
in patent pending design and in our and
they are organized into name columns so
every column has to have a name it has
to have a type and they do optimizations
on the data and under the hood and
that's something that we don't need to
worry about but it is something that
that they provide for the execution in
spark so what we're going to do is bring
in the faithful data set into our with
the faith will underscore RDF I am
naming it that way so that we know what
is an RA and our data frame versus what
is a spark data frame and then we're
going to take the faithful RDF and
create
a data frame in spark so that the
command here is create data frame that
is the one that brings the data into the
spark environment
we're going to crash this park data
frame and persisted in memory only for
our benefit but if you're going to be
working with the data frame that is
going to be read repeatedly and that you
need for a long time it's better to have
it persisted so that if the memory fills
up in the in the cluster it doesn't get
kicked out to do additional tool to
other storage now we're going to run a
few commands that we normally do when we
are doing data analysis up in our and
the first one is str for this structure
this is the structure of the data frame
in our so you see this is the type data
frame and the two columns let's look at
the the object size this is a object
size report the space allocated to of
that object in our so the the data seems
to be taking about 5k in the our
environment now let's do the same for
the spark data frame this dr command
which is an our command gives us
basically the same information it tells
us the type spark data frame and the
name of the two columns and the and also
the type of the columns now if we run
object size we see that this object in
our is only 1k why because that is just
the day the memory that is occupied in
the our environment remember that
picture where we had they are
environment around the driver and this
park around everything else only in our
we have some information is probably the
meta data for this park data frame so
that it does not it does not live in the
our environment it lives in the in the
executors we can take a look
the spark you I and to get there we go
view spark UI gives us another window
so the spark you I gives us information
about the cluster and about what's
happening in the cluster we're not going
to be covering that part about the
configuration and all the cluster but I
wanted you to see that the spark DF is
is located in dec in this bag
environment if we ever get it to work
well this is w that i ran earlier and
you will see that we have a an RDD with
eruptions and waiting and decisive
memories 4.6 kilobytes to get there you
need to go and believe that the w is
jobs but you need to go into storage
that's where that's where the the
information where you will find the
information and by the way we we see
this in storage because we had persisted
that data if we didn't run persist it
will not you will not show up in this
view okay so if you have done spark with
Python before you may you may think of
using show but it does not work the same
in pi spark as it works in our so let's
see how what I get when we get is
basically kind of the same information
of the HDR this park data frame the type
of the data frame and the columns and
their names other types so the next
command that gives us basically the same
information in the print schema and it's
in the true format now we're going to
look everything everyone all right
following along yes
about George okay so under attached
there is a view spark UI and it gives
you another window the window opens
under jobs and you will go and click on
storage and you will see this part okay
okay so now let's let's view the data in
they are data frame as expected you we
get the whole listing of the data frame
and the data in it in it on 270 two data
points now let's try to do that with the
spark data frame and all we get is the
schema of the spike data frame why we
have not run an action into into that
spike data frame to run an action one of
the actions that we will be looking at
is collect let's do collect and collect
works basically brings all of the data
that we just asked it forward to collect
into an hour data frame so the view is
very similar to what we have seen for
the art data frame and we will see the
272 data points but what if you're
working with big data you don't want
that all of the data back into your
environment because that's where you
would run out of memory and that was not
the point in the first place so that's
why you need to be very careful about
using collect you will go directly to
out of memory jail and do not pass go do
not collect 200 dollars so be very
careful with that instead we're going to
learn about other other commands that we
can use
as expected first we'll return the first
row head works the same as seen on our
data frame gives you the first six but
you can also give it a another number if
you want 10 or 15 whatever you want you
would use show DF and it will give you a
nicer a table of what's the content you
will show only the first 20 rows as a
default or you can also give it another
argument and the other one is take that
one needs an argument to know how many
to take usually we would do this to give
it to have an idea of what what what
kind of data we have in our data frame
now one of the things that is unique to
to data bricks is they have a command
called display and you run that let me
if you ran that for the first time you
will see the data displayed in a table
but you can also look at the data in a
different in a different view with a
plot down here there say a button where
you can select the type of plot and
blood options this one has the default
values he found that there are two data
points it said one is X the others why
but later we may be able to to to play
with that okay are we good so far very
good again some fine work we have done
is run an argument into a spark data
frame and see how it behaves and how we
make the command to behave the way we
used to think about it so if you do just
the name of the variable it will not
give you all of the data you have to
collect it but collect very careful
now let's perform some interactive
analysis to start to see how we can
answer some of the questions and one of
the common tasks that we that we would
do in an hour data frame is do the
summary summary will give us the minimum
the maximum the quartiles median the
mean let's try that with a spark data
frame and nothing seemed to have happen
why we did not collect well it was a
lazy execution so we need to have an
action into it I am putting that into
two line so that we can see you first
the command then the collect so so many
on a spark data frame gives us similar
information that the way we have it for
an hour data frame count mean the
standard deviation which is normally not
in for a summer in our but the minimum
and the maximum we can also use
described and described is another
construct that is used in Python and it
will give you the same information so
here they caveat once again just because
you can doesn't mean that you should
just because you can run summary just
because you can run command collect
doesn't mean you should be doing that
because summary will go through all of
the numerical columns it will go and and
try to go to count them to to process
and find out what they mean the standard
deviation the minimum and the maximum so
we have five different operations that
we're running a different statistics
that we're running for all of the new
record college one other difference
behind a summary between a and our data
frame and a spark data frame is so Mary
in an hour data frame will also tell you
a little bit about columns that are
not numerical he will give you if it's a
character will tell you is a character
in and he has two hundred and seventy
two data points and it anime tell you
how many na values are but for a spark
data frame it only runs on numerical
columns okay so to answer our questions
instead of going through the summary
because we can we should not be doing
that let's calculate individually for
each one of our columns what the
questions that we had before to find the
average waiting time it to interruptions
we want to use average or mean and then
the average duration of an eruption also
a racer mean to do that we are going to
use aggregate functions and the syntax
up sorry the syntax is you give it the
name of a den no data frame the
aggregate did the name of the spark data
frame that we want the column aggregate
function or use the alternate syntax so
let's try to calculate the average wait
time between eruptions with the first
syntax notice that waiting here is the
column name mean is the function and I
put it into quote unquote the syntax is
very important and if you don't do it
that way you will give you an error and
you will be crazy at two o'clock in the
morning and the action that we use here
for it was first two we just got one
data point but if we don't do first or
we don't do anything like that it will
not give us the information so to
calculate the average duration of your
options where you see the alternate
syntax notice in this case I the
function is not in quotes we are using a
call to mean with the spark data frame
column but I have to specify both the
name of the data frame and the column
that were using
so it's a little different from the
previous call in the previous code we
did not have a name for the column so
spark already assigned a name with the
with the with the name of the call but
here I had a sign in name for that for
that result so if we do that again we
could access the information that we had
just calculated by going through result
dollar the under name of the column so
this 3.48 is this is stored in the
column you have to go access it from
that column so that's a good reason to
give the colony name we could perform
more than one aggregation at a time in a
call so here we're going to find the
minimum and the maximum a direct
duration and since now it is in in the
duration object we can access both the
minimum and the maximum later if we if
we want to so if you were paying
attention why wasn't but the the end
result is the historically the wait time
between eruptions was 70 minutes and the
usually they last about three point five
minutes but now we went and one thing to
note is that we only did a calculation
in one column where if we need a
calculation that relies about one column
and and something else in another column
and that's where we're going to go for
answering the remaining questions to do
that we're going to use the data frame
operations that include group by select
filter where an arranged and I believe
most of these are already an hour
function
so goodbye creates a grouped data data
frame inside a spark and then we can run
a function on that grouped data if we do
head it has aggregated all of the
waiting are all of the waiting times and
counted how many times they appeared so
70 minutes was four times 67 minutes was
one time etc so let's take a quick look
at that data with the data breaks
display originally you will see a table
like like this but I had selected the
bar chart down here and it gives mostly
a bar chart with the data not not in any
kind of order so remember that the first
data point was 70 with for the next 16
is there not one we can take a quick
look at it and see what's what are the
values now we had we have collected the
data from from the aggregation on
waiting counts that is an hour variable
so now we can also display it with plot
this week and we can influence what are
the options in blood we can have a
better way to look at it even though is
unfortunately it's not as interactive as
the other one when we see 78 has the is
the most common waiting time the other
aggregation aggregate function that
we're using is arranged to to arrange in
descending order all of the waiting
counts and then we can grab that first
one with
with 78 because now to be able to answer
the question of whether the distribution
of the other of the duration of the
eruption we need to get that 78 and find
out with the filter operation filter
would bring in the rows that are going
to satisfy our condition our condition
is that the waiting is the most common
waiting time I change that the way box
flood down here to be able to see that
for the most common waiting time we have
an eruption that lasts between four and
four point six minutes we're done with
that data frame so we can on persistent
elings park you know if you need the
memory go ahead use it for something
else don't worry about it okay so all
faithful was us is said to be erupting
every hour but Wes we have found out for
the historical record it's about 70
minutes they have to wait and it will
last around 3.5 minutes but if you are
lucky to get to the most common waiting
time of 78 minutes then the eruption
would be a little longer from between
four and four five point six minutes
that's quite a show so so far we have
looked at the data frame API we examine
the structure about they are and the
spark data frame and learn about actions
aggregate functions and the operations
everybody following alone oh okay so now
we're going to do the second part of
where we're going to run so much in
learning algorithms with spark to point
know we have an expanded ability to run
machine learning in a spark before we
only have a generalized linear model
with two families the Gaussian and the
binomial but now with spark to point o
we have four different machine learning
models glm the accelerated
failure time survival regression model
and the base model and gay means we also
have the ability to save and load the
modules for later use or for sharing for
this part we're going to do the
classical data set of identifying irises
there are three different irises in the
our data set and they are the Cetacea of
jenika and versicolor we can get
information about that by running the
our command ? iris and we will see that
it has 150 rows and five different
variables telling us what are the
measurements of these of these different
species now let me show you something
that what the this is what the iris
dataset looks like in our he has sip out
dot length I hope that's the right way
to pronounce it she bothered with pedal
dot length and pedal the width and the
species before we read data into a we
put data into spark by having an there
are data frame into spark but how do you
get it into our in the first place if
it's really big data what we need to do
is well what we could do is to read it
from a source either from a CSV file
Jason file or with a database a park air
or sea or or with a connection to AJ
through jdbc there are methods to do
read and to the right so you disable to
do that and what we're going to do is
instead of reading the data from they
are data set we're going to read it from
the data breaks file system just to see
that words now as I mentioned before the
original
data has a dot in the in the name of the
columns and when we run some of the
algorithms is not going to like it so in
this case we have to put in the schema
of the of the data set so i have a
steamer the type and then issued the
fields I name the first one ID and the
type is integral now I change Sipple
underscore length instead of support
length and that's a double same with the
width better length and pedal with then
the species is a string not the
character in in Sparky would be a string
so the function that we're going to use
is read DF and it takes a the path of
where the file is you have to specify
that the source is a CSV that you have a
header and specify what the schema is
now we're going to persist it too so
let's look at the schema and it tells us
the same information that we gave its up
that that's a good thing and as expected
we have the same information that we had
we had before so we're going to run to
machine learning algorithms the first
one is supervised learning in supervised
learning you have a label that you can
train your data on that and the label to
find the structure and it will get and
we create a function that will be able
that you will be able to predict what
the new labels are for the data that he
has not seen so we'll use the binomial
generalized linear model we have three
types of viruses but we're going to run
it only on two to do that I had subset
the data into the versicolor and every
jinnaka to then run a sample and the two
to get the try
data and then do except to do the
testing data and then put it all
together in spark all of this all of
these commands are running with the data
frame inspire I am not bringing the data
into our to be able to do that I tried
to use sample by to do this but it did
not work so some of the things are not
have not been implemented properly okay
now if you notice it only tells me that
the command took 30 point 1 seconds
don't believe it it only you know it's
only doing the execution plan it has not
done anything yet because I have not
asked it to do anything yet now when I
run the glm and I specified the data
frame that I want I want and the formula
i want to to predict the species based
on the measured data and use the family
binomial that's where it's going to
actually do something and it will take
some time a little longer than than all
the other commands aha gabry shots
so if you're familiar with the glm
summary it will give you the residuals
it will give you the coefficients for
your model for your function um and some
information about the performance of the
model now we created a training data set
and any testing data set let's see what
happens when we run the model on the
training data set so with the predict we
give it the model and the spark data
frame with the training data set that we
had remember that training had the ID
the sepal length and everything up to
species the model appended a couple of
columns one of them was the label and
and the other one was the prediction the
label is the label for the species that
we had before so it looks like 0 is
versicolor and one is virginica now the
prediction is these numbers over here
but to be able to find the prediction we
do the if else so that we can properly
classify between 0 and the classy one
class one okay so now we have another
column here with class and the
prediction tote told me that this would
be class 0 it's scroll down to look at
it displaying on data bricks will give
you up to a thousand rows so it is safe
to use up in your driver program aha we
have one that doesn't look like what's
the right one so perfect okay let's
really see how let's really compare the
predictions by building a contingency
table
now I am running count and group by on
the spark data frame I am not bringing
the data frame into art to be able to
see what my predictions are and then I'm
doing collect because I since i'm doing
a continuously table i know that it is
not going to be a lot of data it's going
to be just a table so connect is fine
here we have the printed class with a
predicted class of one and a label of
one which was the the what the training
label was we had 24 but we have a couple
of Miss classified with 0 1 0 1 0 now
let's see how we do on a testing data
set that we haven't seen before we do
the same procedure where we get the
predict to find whether it's the new
prediction with the testing data set and
then put the label the class level 0 1
and build the contingency table we had
to die were misclassified on our on our
testing so for model persistence we
could write the model in into our file
system and then really back if we wanted
to we're not going to be doing that it's
just a throwaway cluster so we don't we
would not do that but if you are
interested i have included links they
are for the documentation now glm
binomial was already included in
previous versions of spark so if you are
running previous versions of spark or
only have access to previous versions
then you will be fine to run that but
unsupervised learning with k-means is
not available yes
dear there are a lot of other commands
that you can do with this spark I am not
including them here but there are a lot
of math functions that are included i
believe from spark 1.5 day they did put
it a lot of them inspire car there is a
link somewhere in the tutorial for the
documentation that you can take a look
at that another question anyone else ha
it looks like we will have enough time
to look at that i put that at the end
just in case we didn't have enough time
but yes we'll look at that and that's a
new spark 2 point 0 for a fissure ok so
let's look at unsupervised learning
there we are not providing a label we
just have that that the data we want to
look at it and find the structure and
we're going to use the k-means
clustering algorithm that gives us
clusters based on what data you pass it
so for the spark k-means algorithm
within days in a spark data frame we
don't have a a predicted level we only
have whether that the columns that we're
going to use for for the prediction now
remember gaming's can only use numerical
data not categorical or anything like
that so if we had something like the
flowers are red and orange or purple we
have to convert that into a number to be
able to include it into the clustering
solicit run the gay means and look at
the summary the summary will give us the
coefficient the coefficients are the
centroid of the clusters then it will
tell us what the size of each of the
clusters are we had three clusters one
is 50 the other 39 and 61 it looks like
we have some stragglers and then the
last one is the cluster assignment if
you notice there it didn't tell us what
the cluster assignment is because each
data point that you passed into the
k-means model is assigned a new cluster
meaning if you have amelia rose and you
get a cluster of minerals right so it's
a spark data frame with a column named
prediction how do we get that well we
could try to incorrect we should not do
collect because that's what I was just
explaining it will bring back the the
prediction for each one of them so
instead
what we want to what we really want to
do is to see that in this park data
frame that we had before and they have
included a predict function for the
k-means which has seen kind of odd for
to me but what it is doing is to
bringing in what cluster number is for
each of the data points now now the
original data frame is using it has add
another column called prediction and
that's the cluster number and again this
is in spark it is you didn't you do not
see it in our i use display to see that
so as before let's build a contingency
table to see the composition of our
clusters we actually have labeled data
we know that the composition is supposed
to be what very close to what the
species are we see that cluster 0 was a
sign all of the citizens were assigned
to cluster 0 but versicolor most of them
47 of them were assigned to cluster 2
and most of the virginica were assigned
to cluster 1 so we have a mix there and
here we can use ggplot2 see the
composition of our clusters again
cluster 0 is 50 of them are thus atossa
cluster 1 is the virginica which is the
blue and then first color is clustered
to as the composition
okay so uh any questions before i go
into the extra module yes
the unsupervised learning does not have
a label it well in in in actual
implementations you don't have a label
you are just telling the algorithm look
at the data tell me how how similar they
are and then clustered and such that the
distance between the center of the
cluster and everybody else is about the
same and that's how the game is
algorithms work we have the luxury I
guess of knowing what the label is for
each one of this of these flowers now
the question is did the people that were
doing the measurement really classified
them well or is there is there a way to
tell that we don't know but it seems
like some of the virginica versicolor
are hard to tell apart so when we were
doing the GLM the the previous algorithm
that had a training level we had some
errors and it was basically because the
data is really is hard to tell them
apart any other questions yes
my understanding is that it will give
you an out of memory and out of memory
error the the configuration parameter
that we saw at the beginning it is
trying to limit and try to help not make
it crush that's what I'm hoping happens
but it depends on your environment right
anyone else what was the second part so
the question was how did the machine
learning algorithms running and the
spark data frame already paralyzed and
aren't already aware of the the spark
data frame structure and the answer is
yes that's one of the reasons why has
taken a little longer to get
implementations in spark are because it
has to be made aware of all of that
those details and to get Diagnostics you
will basically use the spark you I to
look at behind the scenes there is a way
to to look at what's happening behind
the the calculations if you are so if
you want to understand it and this is
this the spark you I again he tells you
what are the stages what it is doing
inside and how it's working see a
timeline of the events and also you can
look at a code that that it may be
running sorry if you are into debugging
that may be a good exercise for you okay
now user-defined functions are one of
the things that they have implemented in
spark to point out there are three
user-defined functions they apply
I and I'll apply and in our
implementations they usually mean what
kind of structure they are working on d4
data frames g4 group data and l4 lists
so before we were working with the
faithful spark data frame and since we
are persistently we need to bring it
back in but and we were doing there
waiting counts the G apply collect up
the G applied and the apply also has a
collect method that immediately brings
you back the information so you can put
the spark data frame the column that you
want to group the information by and
then put your function in the in the in
the call in this case we're doing in row
for account we rename their name the
columns with waiting and count and this
is equivalent to what we had done before
with group by and count so if you run
that should give you the same
information that we had before with a
data frame with the grading counts 17
well let's see now one of the things
that that if you run when you run this
again if you do it with the our data
frame versus the spark data frame the
order that you get your data back from
the spark data frame it will be it may
be out of order it's not necessarily the
same order that you would do it
internally so it's fun to watch but you
have to go back and forth
still calculating just remember you had
to get the data frame I put in the spark
context again and he's doing all of the
grouping and running the function into
that so here the key is the waiting
which which would be the aggregation key
and then X is what else is in the in the
data frame so we're looking for the
number of rows with for that key
so as I mentioned before the apply is
applying a function to each partition of
it a spark data frame I do not have an
example of that in in the tutorial but
if you look at the documentation good
luck and then the applied colleague will
bring the information back and then the
other one that I that I did work with
because I was very curious is to see how
to apply the function that you have from
a library in our we have a lot of
packages that are that that we have with
from our and that we use so spark l
apply will allow you to run a function
over the list of elements and then
destroyed that computation into the
spark environment and apply that
function in there the key here will be
we get back to that one the gear will be
that the library that you're using you
have to put it into the function call so
that you can get that context into the
executors so that they can run that
fortune well um okay let's see looks
that it's finished so we have waiting
count waiting on counter before we had
seven years at the top now we had 67 it
doesn't matter the point is it may be
reordered because of the way that it is
happening in this park data frame it is
distributed it is just collecting it has
no idea of what ordering is ok so let's
go back to this the spark l apply have
to install my package into my our
environment
now I have a list of some large numbers
that I want to find the prime factors
and I am going to run prime factors over
that list and the the library that I'm
using is called numbers so that's the
way to push a library out to the
executors do the calculation and bring
it back so the first one for the first
number the prime factors are three times
three turn thirty six of seven times
3803 gives you that number now the
significance of this example is that my
first experience with the distributed
computation was at the large national
organization that does cryptography and
they wanted to be able to find the prime
factors of these very large key numbers
and what we would do is to distribute
the computation over the the cluster and
the issue of the cluster will have a
piece of prime and a list will have a
list of prime numbers and each of the
clusters would try to factorize the
number the key that we gave it with
those with that list and find out if it
was a factor so I'll included a list a
link of other resources that you may
want to be looking at there are there's
information about running spark on AWS
and also more information about data
frames versus local our data frames
there are other hosted environments I
have used the IBM data scientists work
[ __ ] but it died want doesn't run
sparked appoint not yet so have you used
the 1.6 with IBM and and I know that
they also have a spark on bluemix and
the data science experience
I'll do any are there any other
questions yes
oh yes so good question so one of the
things that then you get from the
summary is the count and and like you
said that there was an approximate count
because the data is destroyed in the
environment they would have to collect
all of them and count them and he may or
may not be happy to be did the one so I
believe that's why they call it a
proxima can so what what I think it's
happening is that they want to do it
fast with an approximate count rather
than the actual count if you have a
large data set you may just want to have
an idea of what's happening okay I am
there are no other questions of thank
you very much for attending our session
and enjoy the rest of pi data Carolinas
I believe there's some information about
lunch